- En Chine, au Japon, en Corée
du Sud où on atteint maintenant
400 000 nouveaux cas par jour,
un peu partout en Asie,
c'c'est la même chose :
Omicron et le sous-variant BA.2
gagnent du terrain.
"La pandémie est encore et
toujours une urgence de santé
publique", dit cet expert
chinois, le seul pays au monde
à maintenir une politique
zéro COVID.
E Europe, on compte maintenant
200 000 nouveaux cas par jour
en Allemagne, 100 000 en France
et au Royaume-Uni, surtout
en raison de la progression
fulgurante du BA.2,
qui va bôôôt détrôner
son cousin Omicron.
- Les États-Unis, avec
maintenant plus de 35 %
des infections causées par BA.2,
estiment qu'ils n'y échapperont
pas et songent déjà
à uososose de rappel.
- Il faut dire que le BA.2 est
de loin le plus contagieux des
variants qui nous ont frappés.
On estime que chaque personne
infectée par le dededede Wuhan
pouvait en contaminer
deux autres. Avec Delta,
c'étaient 4 nouvelles
infections. Omicron, 8.
Et avec BA.2, c'est
potentiellement 12 nouvelles
infections, soit presque autant
que le très contagieux virus
de la rougeole.
Mais il faut rappeler que
ce sous-variant n'est pas plus
dangereux qu'Omicron et
qu'il répond à la vaccination.
ANDRES FINZI, virologue,
Centre de recherche du CHUM- Las
voulez, c'est que les vaccins
continuent de donner
une protection efficace contre
les formes graves causées
par le virus.
- Au Québec, comme partout
ailleurs, une hausse importante
du nombre d'infections
est à prévoir.
Dr GASTON DE SERRES,
épidémiologiste, INSPQ
- Le fait d'avoir beaucoup
de monde qui ont été infectés
depuis le mois de décembre,
ça contribue à ralentir
rararararansmission, mais il re,
malgré tout, plusieurs personnes
qui ont jamais rencontré
le virus et, qui au cours
des prochaines semaines,
devraient probablement
développer ces infections-là.
- Le sous-variant BA.2 est
apparu pour la première fois
en Afrique du Sud au mois
de décembre dernier.
Ici Normand Grondin,
Radio-Canada, Montr